Furby is next in Tennessee hey Kirby
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
and thank you for taking my call sure
how can we help oh I just said well I
wanted to say before my question that
the ramsey name had gone full circle
officially in my house because about 10
years ago my parents went through FPU at
my church I didn't know a little kid I
didn't know about any of that talk
didn't care about it but now that as an
adult I have to care about it
and I've rediscovered you so thank you
for sticking around and helping us out
well thank you sir
it's always good to talk to a financial
peace baby yeah yeah so my question is
that I'm a self-employed musician here
in Nashville and obviously affected by
everything and my industry is shut down
no bars no concerts for the foreseeable
future probably the summer may be the
year so I'm actually successfully
collecting unemployment the 275 plus the
extra 600 which adds up to actually more
than I would make if our working so I
really want to know how to not screw
this up and save absolutely as much as I
can before that runs out or I go back to
work any tips on that okay well the the
written plan the budget is always a
money stretcher okay so jump on it if
you don't have the every dollar budget
loaded onto your phone jump on and load
the world's best budgeting app it's free
to use it's called every dollar and
it'll help you put together your budget
because money that is told what to do
behaves a lot better than money that
runs wild right and you just it just
goes further and so and you know you're
just making choices because you're
choosing to say rather than this impulse
or luxury yeah or whatever it is even if
it's a minor luxury rather than that I
would rather have the money in savings
for when this runs out
and so you make these choices very
consciously when you put it on a budget
right in front of you yeah and Kirby
you're already thinking the right way my
friend where you're going hey you don't
know how long this is gonna last so you
don't know how much of that you're gonna
need so you know so you being
intentional on the front end what you're
gonna do is end up protecting that money
from running around and leaving you for
it okay so what baby step are you on
right now so I wouldn't I would like to
reach I don't know if it's two or three
that the three to six months do best
baby I got my emergency I'm the only bet
I have is my car credit card debt or
even student loans I didn't go to school
so I I would like to have that three to
six months and by likely by August yeah
you're not you're not really working the
baby steps right now you're in the
middle of a crisis so what you're doing
is just yeah you're just gonna pile up
cash yeah okay guys we would have you
pay off the car before an emergency fund
that's right if you were working the
baby steps but right now you're in a
crisis you don't need to do that you
need to pile up the cash and then and
also I want you to rethink how you might
use your musical talent what the venue
is it's not not necessarily a you know a
honky-tonk
situation may be prior maybe private
parties maybe zoom sings for something I
don't okay oh great all right you know
how can you deliver your service your
your artistry in different ways than
this in the meantime
and then hopefully it will start to get
back to normal at some point but
Nashville's coming back slower as you've
already discovered then the rest of the
state this is the city itself the mayor
there's held a lot tighter than the rest
of the state has on the oak tree
openings so you're that's what you're
sitting in the middle of Ben though hey
you know what that brings up a point
maybe you move not move but maybe you
offer your services outside of nice
in the surrounding counties the adjacent
counties are opening yeah that's a great
point there might be there might be some
things you can do legally you know under
the current reopening with that the
governor's doing that's applying maybe
maybe there's I don't I don't know who
this is but there's got to be some
locations that might consider hiring you
you probably probably got some
competition because everybody's on the
street in your work oh absolutely and
they're thinking but here's the thing as
they pointed out if if your hours have
been cut or your job has been lost
you're going into conserved mode you're
piling up money and saving it however
once things do stabilized for you you've
got that money into savings now that if
you were on baby step to an attack in
debt you would just go to that savings
and apply it to the debt following the
order so it's a temporary pause until
you stabilize is the most important
thing this is not money that's just
gonna fritter itself away we got to be
intentional with it yeah so I think what
if I'm in your shoes a combination of
the cash I can pile up and the unusual
side gigs I can here hustle and grind
side gigs I can get the combination of
those two things will allow me to be
ready for when the unemployment runs out
and if if things are not back to normal
by then and so that's that's some really
good planning on your part so jump
online and get the every dollar app
going